hi everyone I'm David Griffin and I'm
Michael Medina in order to bring you
this week's review of arrow season 2
episode 20 seen red wow this one had a
big ending it yes it really gets that
last the big thing i want to talk about
so seeing red you know is alluding to
you know the red hood that all yes do is
just do this and you are hidden you know
hey even you know Felicity can't catch
you on cares like oh that must why that
was like where's red hood it's just like
that they do that Joe stealth to
wherever I can forget games like
splinter cell about Tom Clancy just get
a red hood nobody to go where to go so
this episode as interesting I mean we
got to kind of talk about a piece by
piece because you could look at the end
be like oh snap yeah it's great but to
be honest like it kind of started off I
was like okay where's all this going no
island now so we got a flashback to a
longer here blond-haired Moira and some
a wig you know on Ali so bad with bad
wigs what do you think about that um
well as a whole i thought the episode it
started off kind of slow Freddie mmm I
thought I'm like it'sit's I don't want
to say was filler but it's just kind of
filling in certain holes yeah following
Mora and her her race to be mayor um but
then again you know we'll talk about
that later I ended with a bang kind of
made up for all that because then like
you said you're wondering like you know
where all this was going and then you
kind of see that at the end but all in
all I thought it was a solid episode I
thought the flashbacks again it was one
of those things are like where's this
going exactly than it does serve a
purpose and I thought it was well done
and I'd very well Donny the episode
wrapped up very well I thought it was
very touching you know especially which
we'll get to in a little bit you know
again you know it is still arrow you
know sorry Boyd diggle's not doing much
you know he was hungry thank goodness
gonna get some food you know no big no
big belly burger than I can go there
anymore I can't go there anymore so I'm
see who else do we see I mean this was a
very Moira centrica well also oh and
also also our villain yeah this
particular episode which was Roy Roy no
Roy which starts off with him obviously
it takes place you know i'm assuming few
days or whatever after they rescued him
stuff so he's on a table they're trying
to figure out what's wrong with them and
and all sunny juror exactly just kind of
springs to life and then you know makes
it voy a point to put this hood on first
thing up with
got ya it's important to be stealth very
happy you have absolutely but obviously
makrooh is just reacting in a negative
way right now and to a point where he
just can't control it's not even him
anymore yeah you know and here's a
stroke well Slade has easterlies issues
he sees you know shadow he can think he
can control it a little bit more you
know he still has issues you know he
still has issues but yeah Roy is
definitely off the deep end yeah boys
yeah he's not in the same for you can
barely even speak but um you know so he
attacks you know everyone and stuff and
just kind of goes on a rampage of the
city killed a police officer yeah you
know causing all kinds of havoc then
basically to the point where Sarah and
this is where it gets kind of
interesting you know cuz we saw and he
makes a reference to this as well last
season how in the early days of him
coming back from the island he was
basically just like kill first alright
was later know what I mean and he's
grown a lot since then and you said
Sarah still that type of person you know
and she might always be that no not like
you know go to hit cuz I think Lucy said
well maybe she'll come to your side I'm
like maybe not yeah she was also with
the League of Assassins she's a little
bit of a harder edge which leads us to
her departure in her telling Ollie that
I gotta go see an old friend oh sorry
telling sin ya talkin two cents in shows
up you know I mean she kinda just pops
in and out what she's not really that
important i don't think but anyway since
shows up and says you know where he
Goins like i got a scene old friend i
think it might be nice' I Bielecki
writing of other friends she could but
that girl he saw as a friend if you know
what I'm saying it was a really real
friend so I think she might be going to
see her well I bring her back to the end
yeah I mean cuz first of all I just
thought she was a great character a
great addition to the show um maybe we
might not see her this season but I hope
at least next year alright in point
they'll bring she was great right now
and I guess I guess we'll have no not
first before we go into the end sets
that's the big stuff let's talk about
Ali's child yeah so which we did a
little research uh he does have a kid
well yeah yeah well there's Connor
Connor you know at first it I didn't
quite put two and two together but then
you know with like the one night stand
and you know her the mother going away
and so I just was like that seems from
New
so I mean it's not confirmed aab not
only but it kind of makes sense well
only be a cask honor yet but I mean he
does have a son in the comic book yeah
this kid now would be seven years old
you know i'm assuming give or take you
know so i mean i'm curious to see if
we're actually gonna see Connor maybe
not this season like yeah like who's
your baby like what about me yeah maybe
maybe not the father you order yeah
maybe next season yeah and maybe even
not even next season like I wouldn't
mind if it was like I don't know like
maybe couple years now he's a little bit
older maybe kind of like speed up time a
little bit 73 this time way yeah he'll
come back at like 15 I mean unless I
could make him look into a Damien yeah
what everything that would be yeah it
really made him like a dick this
basically is Batman Green I mean the way
he talks like you feel duty I mean here
does it say sniffing that comic so this
is basically Batman but yeah again let's
lead in let's go into the end the big
part that we didn't see coming because
the episode was any learn that limo
they're driving and they're just like
hello family moment I'm like okay this
episode was Oh first of all let's not
forget leading up to that seen this is
kind of big oh yeah Moira reveals to
Oliver that she actually knows very good
she knows that he's out and that's you
that was she she knows he's arrow she
said that she's actually been knowing
for a year or so right like that and
that was huge which you know right there
should've been a dead giveaway that
something was gonna happen and right
when she was about to tell the secret
about Malcolm Merlyn does one more thing
you could tell you boom boom like we
kind of thought like you know you even
said like you know screening idea and
you know and live hangout have been it
and then like it's gonna go but like you
know it kept going you know there was
you know you know hallucinating and
waking up and you see Oliver looking and
what I didn't expect is Slade now is
playing hardball happy was just planning
kind of verbal seeds you know he didn't
hurt Thea yeah um he didn't hurt Laurel
uh you know he went and visited them and
stuff didn't hurt them now he was
getting physical we did always say to
that basically he was going to have to
experience that same time right and
that's one thing i love about Slade and
just many Pinette in general cuz just I
feel like completely killing this case
yeah amazing on the show but you know
it's basically the same scenario that I
50 put Oliver in it on Oliver in like
five six years ago on the island and I
thought that was kind of cool and I
thought the tension building up again
with those flashbacks with Oliver's mom
and stuff in all the stuff that we saw
her go through kind of covering up for
Oliver's you know unplanned pregnancy
and stuff just kind of shows the kind of
what lengths showed other kids she's got
some past she has a past mm-hmm um if
I'm gonna be honest I'm kind of sad that
she's she's gone I I actually not that I
want anybody to die yeah you know good
lord after our game of thrones first I
did I meet people think I'm like pro
like like abuse or something so it's got
to be careful i say what it's like like
what I'm saying is I don't want anybody
to die but at the same point I think
Moira though her mayoral campaign wasn't
that interesting yeah she is a character
to gym because she knew rachele ghoul at
least she used his name she's she used
his name enough to scare Malcolm Merlyn
away who's a powerful guy whereas Thea
again like Laurel is kind of becoming
the damsel in distress yeah I feel like
very much I almost feel like the writers
having a hard time figuring out where to
go with her because now that Laurel kind
of went through her issues or whatever I
feel like the same thing with her as
well like she knows about Oliver she
knows about all them where do you take
this character the same thing we said
for Thea because you know where do you
take a character like that from this
point on and um and that's why I'm kind
of said also that more is gone because
yes I thought her you know her race to
be mayor stuff was a little weird
whatnot whatever I thought she was still
an interesting character and had a lot
of potential like again with the whole
you know knowing who ratio was in her
dark past I thought could still offer a
lot more to the show so it's a shame
that you know they would have gone she
was one character I didn't really know
what her endgame was especially because
I when you drop ratio girl's name it's
like that's big like how do you know him
look your moments when she seemed like a
genuinely good person right mother but
then she turned around right Abby in the
back yeah which I thought made her
interesting right in fact that she knew
Oliver was cool with it so the crowd of
you that was awesome so that was a great
scene and then I don't know everybody
caught this but this was actually kind
of cool you notice it's laid gives Moira
a more honorable death yeah cuz the
first I saw him switch weapons it didn't
click it first like he had the gun he
put it away into got a sore but his
sword is a more like kind of the whole
falling on your sword thing the more
ritualistic type of death like he could
have shot her to have but that would
have been too
yeah I know did acknowledge the fact
that you know she's encouraged in fact
that you know the shame didn't pass it
on to your children oh but uh yeah I
mean it just shows again just like the
lengths that morale will go through
right there are kids and with Slade will
go through like completely torment
Oliver he did say he's gonna give him a
slow death yeah you know what i mean and
up until his actual one so i thought
that was really good it's good i think
Oliver I think too i think i was gonna
kill again cuz he did say I would kill
like I don't think I hope he does I
don't I don't want sleeper so I don't
want Slade to die yeah but I kind of
hope he does kill again just because I
don't I think it'd be too easy if he was
just like oh I'm a good person I'm not
gonna kill he's so angry and so enraged
you killed his mom like he's gonna kill
somebody well somebody well here's the
thing and that's a good point but you
think of Batman again he's a string
Batman your parents were murdered you
know this is that is driving first why
you know he's wage this war against evil
and stuff but he doesn't kill doesn't
use guns and is I think that [ __ ] kind
of shows just the complexity of a
character like Oliver to actually deal
with something like this because Slade
is pushing him to limit how he'd never
had to go through before so the fact
that he's dealing with this and if he
still kind of stays on that path I'm not
killing and trying to do something you
know be more of a noble person so I
think they'd be interesting kind of cool
to see because again it's like he is
arrow he did set out on this mission he
didn't make this vow to not kill and
stuff and I think it just kind of
lessons a character a little bit if he
just basically kind of lessons himself
to his level they're gonna start killing
so yeah yeah so we got to get into now I
guess you know are just our theories are
going to talk about we have three
episodes left three without a break this
is great the final 30 this is gonna be
23 episodes long that's over two seasons
of Game of Thrones my goodness it was
like oh so Mike I was like wow thought
this was season three's I'm like is this
season feels like if you watch it from
october to two may it's like hey I mean
hey not complaining i like this show but
network television good lord oh yeah so
we have three episodes left this is
gonna be this is gonna be pretty dark
ending I think we have we have a Sarah
going off possibly visiting Mesa maybe
maybe we'll see two al Ghul come back
maybe we'll see we'll see obviously a
Deathstroke Oliver confrontation
for sure ravager you know we've already
talked about that she's in the trailer
for next week's episode yeah you know
she's gonna come into play so how're
things is all gonna end like who's left
standing at the end well first of all
it's not gonna have a happy ending no I
think it's safe to say like you're
saying with Slade and stuff he's too
good of a character to kill right he's
not going anywhere I mean I think maybe
his role might lessen a little bit come
next season you don't want to over you
think he's a fan everybody I've heard
say we've seen in the comments who
talked to us they said they loved menu
but never love is performing even people
have it like I know you haven't seen
Spartacus yet little haven't seen
Spartacus but they so say well this
guy's good let me check out his other
stuff really like people like man you
but I don't think they'd get rid of them
and that's there but you don't want to
over use a character like you guys
played well definitely a public low-key
exact almost exactly you've met a bigger
role this season in season one so last
season he had a smaller role you know is
a big role but still smaller was just
basically you know just flashbacks this
season you get the flashbacks as well as
everything is doing currently so again
going into season three you don't want
to over use a character like that
because then you know people might get
tired them cuz they're other villains
you know Oliver new take on so you know
his role a lesson which is why I think
they're just kind of going you know
balls to the wall right now but someone
like like say and that's a good thing
but again so I think he's gonna be fine
um i don't i don't know about ravager on
yeah i don't know i think she might be
one of those characters i think not
saying she's gonna die the reason but I
think she's definitely a character i
could see dying somewhere down the line
so it's kind of upsetting that we didn't
get to see a lot of her you know summer
glau she was gone for so long so i hope
they this is the last like this last
three episodes yeah and also we can't
forget we still have Suicide Squad
absolutely the trailer you see more and
that you know big Suicide Squad Show did
you see more of Harley Quinn you know
come out look with her pigtails and
everything so we know she's gonna be a
bigger player like so we got to see some
more sousa and that's the thing like how
much can I'm there's only through
episode yeah that can only accomplish I
think a lot of its gonna be carryover
just using that and that's why I say
it's definitely not any gonna with a
happy ending and something I can't be
first of all just like how do you wrap
something like that up you can't there's
so much story to tell and you know it's
so good that I want it to keep going
yeah you know what I mean cuz you do so
you still have brother blood I mean he's
kind of right now just kind of a
stroke Lackey oh you like to see him
kind of step up a little bit more sure
down the line we will ya who will see
that uh but yeah I think I don't know it
is they're gonna come back you know
maybe she would be next season or the
end of the yeah something you know
there's there's always Huntress floating
around in prison somewhere those are all
dad's in prison everybody's in jail I
feel like right now the show is kind of
like up in the air and in a good way
because I like the fact that I don't
know what's coming yeah you know because
you've got Thea you've got Laurel what's
gonna happen to Roy right what I mean
because as we've seen these these series
especially with arrow they adhere to the
comics but they're not following one
story yeah I see Isabel rochev is the
perfect example that summer glau is a
combination of rules Wilson and Isabel
rochev put together into ravager which
is cool so we never know we're going to
see you know this series just keeps
getting better this episode was great
and ending I didn't see coming Mike and
I didn't see that coming caught us off
guard made a mediocre episode into a
great episode if you look at the episode
as a whole employer thing together
photos is an excellent episode so as
always like to hear what you think you
can come find us at think you're calm
you're also gonna check us out on this
YouTube channel a think hero pro be sure
to subscribe like you know give us a
thumbs up here and of course what should
i get to your comments as soon as we can
also wrong twitter i'm at think here or
sorry we're all I think hero dennis
michael myself you want to chat with us
we can get to you there personally i'm
at griffin de and i'm at mr. michael
Alexis we also have a Facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think your
fans be sure to you know use of social
media spread the word the arrow love we
appreciate all your support sorry for
the blader review last week we're all
just seeing everybody's busy doing a
thing out here so yeah I can't wait to
see you next week
you